the great pleasure for me to be here and
the lecture here um I don't know if you
know that but there is really this close
connection between deep mind and UCL
which started off by two of our founders
Thomas and Shane meeting as post
doctoral fellows at UCL and then ending
up founding deep mind so really at the
very root of things deep mind and UCL
are connected and I think it's great
that we can celebrate that and and use
it and by putting out this lecture
series and and sharing these thoughts
together I will only be the first of
several lecturers here are all the
lecturers within the series and you will
get to know these people if you stick
through their lectures and they have a
lot of interesting and wonderful things
to say and towards the end of this
lecture I'm going to go through the
topics that they will cover and try to
motivate them in the context of the
larger field of deep learning here's the
plan for the lecture first wheeled self
intelligence and and then we'll do some
other things when I have the word
solving intelligence here that refers to
the first part of deep minds mission
deep minds missions Hadley has these two
parts first solve intelligence and
second use it to solve everything else
and well that is of course an audacious
mission statement we do believe that
it's a great North Star to guide our
research and so far it it has created a
lot of great momentum so I could talk
about deep learning in a very broad
sense giving examples from all walks of
life but I'm sure you're familiar with
most most of those and so I'll take a
more personal view a more deep
centric view also because that's the
work that I can authentically speak
about and so what I would like to do is
go through three case studies of
successful deep learning applications to
show you the power of deep learning and
to motivate you to study it further and
in these three case studies a lot of
things will come up that you might not
understand at this point in time fully
but then I can assure you that the
subsequent lectures will fill in those
gaps and and make you appreciate what's
happening here so the first case study
is alphago and alpha0 the second one has
a little more action to it learning to
play the game of capture the flag and
the third one goes beyond games and is
about folding proteins with alpha fold a
deep learning based system and it takes
us into the realm of biology and science
and then finally the last bit of the
lecture I want to go over the the pieces
that the subsequent lectures will
deliver and put them into a greater
context to tell you what's out there and
why it's worth learning about these
things so let's start with solving
intelligence the hallmark of human
intelligence is its generality and
nobody has expressed this in a crisper
way than the science fiction author
Robert a Heinlein so he says a human
being should be able to change a diaper
plan an invasion butcher a hog Koerner
ship design a building write a sonnet
balance accounts build a wall set a bone
comfort the dying take orders give
orders cooperate act alone solve
equations analyze a new problem pitch
manure program a computer cook a tasty
meal fight efficiently die gallantly
specialization is for insects now
nothing accounts against insects because
they are actually smart in their very
own way
and I'm not sure we have actually fully
reached that level of intelligence yet
but for the purpose of this definition
the idea is the ability to do a wide
range of things well is a
characterization of intelligence now my
colleague Shane leg is very passionate
about the definition of intelligence so
passionate that he sifted through over
70 definitions of intelligence before he
arrived at his own synthesis and his
definition is intelligence measures an
agent's ability to achieve goals in a
wide range of environments you see how
that's connected to the Heinlein quote
and to what we think of as intelligent
behavior now why is this important well
if we want to create artificial
intelligence we better have some kind of
idea how to measure success how to know
when we have an intelligent agent now
Shane also has mathematics at his heart
close to his heart and so he has a
formal theory of this definition of
intelligence and we will not go into the
details but I would just like to point
briefly pointed out so this measure of
intelligence here on the left is a
function of PI a policy where a policy
determines what action to take in a
given state now this measure of
intelligence is expressed as the sum
over environments and this term
represents the breadth of all the things
that an intelligent agent should be able
to do and he formalizes this in the
framework of algorithmic information
theory and so he talks about the sum
over all computable environments now we
need some something that indicates
success and that's this term here the
value that policy PI creates in
environment mu so how successful is that
policy or
we expose it to that particular task or
environment and here's this thing in the
middle is a complexity penalty a waiting
term K of MU is the comic or of
complexity of the environment mu and so
what this says is that if this
complexity is low then this term is
great and if this complexity is high
then this term will be smaller and so
the definition gives more weight to
simple environments and then
progressively less weight to more
complex ones of course there are many
more complex environments than simple
ones and so it also acts as a
normalization now the notion of the
value and the policy come from a
framework called reinforcement learning
and in many ways we think of it as a
very general purpose framework for AI
the idea is that there's an agent and
the agent interacts with an environment
and that environment poses some kind of
task or problem to the agent if you like
and so the agent here represented as a
neural net observes the state of that
world and can then take an action in
that world and influence the world and
once it has taken that action it
receives the subsequent observation what
has happened as a consequence of that
action and it receives the reward
symbolized by the star here is there
some kind of positive impact on the
agent some measure of success and the
goal of this agent is to learn a policy
you know the PI from the previous
definition such that it maximizes
long-term reward so ideally it doesn't
just go for the immediate reward but it
it plans ahead it tries to act in such a
way that in the long term it will be
successful in this environment now the
beautiful thing is that this framework
is so general some people would say
overly general that it encompasses
things like unsupervised learning and
supervised learning as special cases
but if you want to learn more about it
there is actually a module that
colleagues of mine are teaching at UCL
here on reinforcement learning so this
framework will be important going
forward in those first two applications
of deep learning that I'm going to talk
about and the reason is that the
combination of deep learning and
reinforcement learning we also refer to
it as a deep reinforcement learning is
such a powerful combination that we can
use to solve interesting interactive
problems out there in the world now we
started a lot of our work with games and
you might be aware of the work on atari
games very early on and why do we do
that
well first of all games are a bit like
this reinforcement learning you know you
interact with this world and try to
solve problems really often they're a
microcosm of the real world if you think
about typical games you know they are
about value monopoly is about money and
buying and selling and chess is about
has spatial dimensions and time built
into it and disease is a war game they
have been designed to stimulate
intelligence the designers of this game
specifically want to stimulate human
intelligence so clearly they must have
some aspect to them that is is of
interest when we want to build
intelligence the great thing is we can
simulate games you know we can set up
simulations large-scale computer
simulations and and learn very quickly
by playing these games and finally games
are great for us to measure progress
because often there's some kind of
winning or score or success measure
associated with games they just think of
video games with the little score
indicator you know you want to ramp up
that score that's great that's a way of
measuring progress and in the context of
our L of reinforcement learning it can
also serve as a reward so that's what it
looks like then if we apply deep
reinforcement learning to a game in this
case pong you know the ideas are the
same the agent observes the environment
and take
actions and then the score here is the
reward that the agent gets the reward
that is trying to maximize in the long
term and then in deep reinforcement
learning the policy here the thing that
decides in a given state what action to
take drastic up drastic down and so on
based on seeing this pixel image in this
case that is parameterized by a neural
network whose parameters were trying to
adapt so that the agent has success in
the long term for example optimizing
long term discounted reward so in this
particular application my colleagues ran
these reinforcement learning algorithms
over close to 50 different Atari games
and achieved superhuman level in a lot
of these games really by putting the
controller into the hand of the
reinforcement learning algorithm letting
it play these games observing the screen
if you like the pixels on the screen and
training the system to maximize reward
or game score in these games and I just
want to use this as an example for how
to think about Shane's definition you
remember there was the sum over
environments and the value that the
agent generates in these environments
now think of the set of environments as
these games and then if we have an
algorithm that can do well in all of
these games then according to Shane's
definition we might be tempted to call
that agent to have acquired some degree
of intelligence of course not anywhere
close to human intelligence but you know
just that ability to solve many
different tasks to a high standard as
the hallmark of intelligence okay so
what's the role exactly of deep learning
here well in previous machine learning
work prior to the deep learning wave if
you like for every problem that you
wanted to solve with machine learning
you first need to define features that
describe the state of
the problem you know for documents that
would be bag of words features and for
visual problems that would be particular
filters that people defined edge
detectors and so on and the new thing
with deep learning not new now but you
know it was back then is to enable
end-to-end learning to put the raw
features the pixels near the raw
description of the problem in and learn
the desired input output mapping just
given the loss how you measure success
and the architecture of your neural
network that's really what I would call
the the definition of deep learning
now one beautiful thing about deep
learning is that through the
architecture we can put prior knowledge
into the solution of our problem and
that makes learning easier in other
words it requires less training data if
we can do that and hence also less
compute and we will talk a little more
about this later but this prior
knowledge could for example be about
space and be about time those basic
kunti and notions if you like now what
makes deep learning possible and
attractive now I would argue it's the
great computational power that we have
available now GPUs TP use and so on it's
the large amount of data that we now
have generated by mobile devices online
services distributed sensors labels
generated by crowdsourcing by people if
you like and finally our better
understanding of algorithms and
architectures and there's a great
opportunity here because a lot of these
algorithms are out there you know
they're an uncute hub you can download
them and play with them and a lot of the
papers are an archive you know as soon
as they're written people upload them on
the archive and there's a huge
repository of information there to get
started in deep learning good ok I would
like to move on now to these case
studies and start off with alphago and
alpha zero some of you may have heard
about these projects and so I hope I can
deliver some some more details on these
and give you the general gist the core
paper that I want to talk about is this
paper a general reinforcement learning
algorithm that masters chess shogi and
go through self play learning with my
great colleagues David silver tomorrow
bear Julien Schmidt feasor and Eunice
and no blue and others what you see here
is the scene where were ad job who we
also call the hand of alphago
because he acts as alpha goes hand where
he plays and here lee sedol on the other
side in this 2016 match which was
captured in in this Netflix documentary
that you might want to check out if you
haven't seen it so what's the problem
with go go is a beautiful game complex
with beautiful strategies doesn't take
long to learn but a lifetime to master
and the problem is that there are so
many different moves in any given
position the 361 vertices on which you
can take turns to place black and white
stones to surround territory and there's
just so many different ways in which
games can develop and that's where deep
learning kicks in and in particular we
use two neural networks to reduce the
size of the search space the space of
possible games in which we need to do
our planning the first one we call the
policy network and the policy network
takes as input a raw goal position
you're now characterized by empty black
and white points on this 19 by 19 grid
and maps it to a probability
distribution over moves so given a go
position this thing is a probability for
each move being played in a particular
position now we have a second neural
network we call the value network and
the value network also takes a given
position but it just produces one number
basically the evaluation of that
position is this position good for black
or is it
good for white and how was this trained
in alphago well we were lucky we had
access to a lot of human game records
that people had recorded from very
strong players and so the first thing we
could do was imitation learning we could
use deep learning to learn the policy
network to really just learn to imitate
the human players and that gave us the
weights for the policy network you know
the network observes a position it
observes the professional or the highly
skilled move played in that position and
now it's a simple mapping from the input
board representation to that label if
you like now at that point we had a
policy network that was able to play in
a similar way to very strong human
players it could imitate them so we
could use that neural network to very
quickly generate more games and so we
generated a lot of games that then
allowed us to train the value network
because what the value network requires
is an again an input representation for
the board and the outcome of the game
did black win or did white win and from
very many such pairs it can then learn
the probability for any given position
for black or white to win and this is
already a form of reinforcement learning
because we're learning the value
function that I talked about earlier now
how do we use these neural networks they
actually use them much in the way that
humans would use their intuition when
they approach the game the problem is
there's this huge search tree when you
expand from a given position all the
different ways black can play than all
the counters by white and black and
white and so on it's a huge search space
and it would be hopeless to just try and
plan within that space if you didn't
have any guidance but these two neural
networks they give us that guidance the
policy network allows us to be smart
about the moves that we choose we don't
need to check out all the moves that
start from this position
we can focus on the promising ones on
the ones where the professional or
strong go player would be likely to play
and that biases the search in the right
direction now the problem that remains
is that the game tree is still very deep
a typical game of go can last 200 moves
250 moves even longer sometimes so how
do we deal with that that's where the
value net comes in because we don't need
to go all the way to the end of the game
to observe its outcome if black wins or
white wins we can stop somewhere in the
middle after a few moves and use the
trained value network to give us an
estimate of how good the position is for
black or for white and so together the
policy network and the value network
reduce the size of this huge search tree
and allow us to traverse it and find
good plans in it and that's what alphago
does and it worked we weren't always
sure it would work but in 1968 in 2016
we had the match against isa dal a
phenomenal 9dan professional go player
from korea and at that point no program
had ever beat a professional player at
that level in a match and in a very
exciting match alphago ended up winning
four games to one and if you want to
share that excitement I really recommend
that you take a look at this Netflix
documentary alphago which details our
paths there and and also the drama of
the match good so much for alphago but
we weren't quite happy with that because
alphago go is just one game right and so
we said that intelligence requires us
the agent to be able to solve more than
one game maybe three games you know not
much but a little better and so I'd like
to talk about alpha zero and and how
that managers not only to play
two more games but also use much less
human knowledge because remember alphago
was still using those professional game
records and also some some additional
features that we had designed and so
what's interesting is that a short story
by Stefan spike the Royal game can give
us some insight into how alpha0
approaches the SPRO this problem
you see here on the right Stefan's like
the author and the book tells the story
of dr. B an innocent man who has been
arrested and is being held in solitary
confinement not unlike our learning
agents that the B is alone in his small
world and starved for stimulation I
quote they did nothing other than
subjecting us to complete nothingness
for as is well known nothing on earth
puts more pressure on the human mind
than nothing while waiting for an
interrogation dr. B manages to steal a
book from one of his captors a book
about the game of chess eager to engage
his mind dr. B devours the book and
learns to play chess on a makeshift
board in his cells he replaced the
master games from the book over and over
again but after a few weeks the games
from the book have lost their novelty
desperately looking for further
diversion dr. B attempts to play chess
against himself but he soon realized
that he can only play against himself if
he splits his mind into two halves and I
black and then I white only now with two
agents in play through interaction and
learning can happen
later on a cruise ship dr. B meets the
world chess champion of the time when
Mirko sent ovitch an expert at chess and
only at chess in a stunning
demonstration of his skills dr. B
manages to do the impossible he wins at
chess against the world chess champion
now fast forward 80 years and Stefan
Sykes story becomes reality in a way
that not even the author could have
imagined and he could imagine a lot
the modern center which stock fish the
world computer Chess Champion 2016 a
good old-fashioned AI for playing chess
and only chess the modern dr. B I would
argue alpha0 an artificial agent that
learns to play chess solely by playing
against itself now here you see some
results as white alpha zero wins almost
30 percent of its game against his games
against stock fish and as black it
manages to draw most of the time and
even wins the humor games then stock
fish does you have to imagine stock fish
is an is a good old-fashioned AI a
program that has been designed by people
by chess experts and so on and uses an
enormous number of heuristics to cut
down the search tree and uses all kinds
of domain knowledge about chess now here
you see the development over time as
alpha zero trains this is the route
these are thousands of steps and you see
here the e low number that's how we
measure success here and after roughly
four hours of training alpha zero
surpasses stock fish in its chess
skills
so how does this work the trick of
course is a form of reinforcement
learning and self play as you may have
inferred from this story alpha zero is
also all alone in some sense playing
chess against itself and here's how it
works
so initialized with the policy and value
network alpha zero plays by evaluating
the search tree from a given position in
making its best move then taking that
next position again taking policy and
value net and tree search to evaluate
its net next move and so on and so forth
it plays in place in place and generates
a lot of games at its current level of
chess which is very low at the beginning
because it's just starting and P and V
there are at this point almost random
but then now we have games generated and
we can train the policy network because
now we have a position and we know which
move was made and we can train the
policy network to imitate that move we
can do that for the next position and
the next position and so on the move
made by alpha zero previously is the
label from which the policy network
learns it's basically imitating itself
augmented by search similarly we can
train the value Network and predict the
winner of these games because we know
those games we've played them all the
way to the end so for a given position
we know how it will end and we can train
in your network that estimates that now
finally we put these new policy and
value networks into the tree search and
generate new games let alpha zero play
against itself but now at a higher level
because the new policy network and the
new value network are better and hence
together with the tree search they
generate better moves and we can
generate higher quality games of chess
that's how it works and it actually
works not only for chess but also for go
and for shogi and these are just
comparisons to how long it takes to over
to reach the levels of the more
traditional kind
tenders for being the best programs in
this space now one thing that I found
very interesting is how does alpha zero
reason about chess positions in order to
appreciate that you need to understand
that a classical chess program on the
left evaluates tens of millions of
positions before it makes a remove it
expands the tree to that many nodes now
alpha zero only expands about tens of
thousands of positions less by a factor
of a thousand
so it's search is much more focused and
of course that still a far cry from how
human grandmasters operate because they
only evaluate hundreds of position their
intuition for chess is so great that
they are very good at both selecting the
lines they look at and evaluating the
resulting positions but you see here
that in some sense we've made a move
from this brute force approach towards
the smarter way of solving these
problems that humans employ one thing I
like is that we actually discovered some
chess knowledge here or not we actually
alpha zero did you know for example
traditional openings like the English
opening was discovered by alpha zero and
it continues to play it there's there's
other openings that are also known to
humans that are discovered
but then discarded you know not good
enough alpha zero understood that that
line although it's been played by humans
for a long time you know just not good
enough I want to give you one example of
play of alpha zero this is my favorite
game it's called the immortal souped
swung game super strong is a german word
that indicates a situation in which it's
not actually advantageous for a site to
move but they'd rather stay still and do
nothing but the rules of chess don't
allow that so what you see here is alpha
zero as white and stockfish as black and
you see here that whites pieces are very
active and black is very crammed into
this corner with the Queen in the corner
blocked by that rock the King also
blocked in these two
rocks protecting that porn it doesn't
look good and now we can take a look at
which moves actually or which pieces
black cannot move in this situation and
the tragedy of the position if you like
is that moving any of these pieces leads
to a loss for black and so you see that
alpha zero has a real appreciation of
these positional advantages the mobility
of the pieces and and dominating the
board okay let's conclude the learning
helps us conquer this huge search space
and self play produces the large amount
of data that we need to train these deep
neural networks there's also another
thing at play which we call an automatic
curriculum because you know at the at
the beginning the system starts to play
in a very weak fashion and as it becomes
better its opponent also becomes better
and so it always trains against opponent
that's just of the right level because
it's training against itself and that
automatic curriculum leads to stronger
and stronger play and the system
discovers new knowledge which i think is
is a beautiful property of AI systems
there's still many open questions it's
just a game and relatively small spaces
as opposed to real world situations but
it's an interesting first step there's
more material that you can look at if
you're interested now let's move to a
more action filled game learning to play
the game of capture the flag this is
based on a recent science paper with max
jailer burg Wojtek Ronettes key and in
Dunning and it's about playing the game
of capture the flag so it's a large
scale a decentralized multi agent
learning problem because capturing the
flag is an objective game where multiple
agents need to learn to interact to play
it well and you see here a first-person
perspective and here a top-down view of
a typical game situation
how does this game work well this we
play it as a 2v2 game the you go run to
the opponent base and pick up the flag
you want to bring it back to your own
base but you need to make sure that when
you capture it that your own flag is at
your own base let's take a look at this
from the game's perspective here this is
the agent perspective and this is the
top-down perspective and you'll see how
this game works so you see the blue
agents there they're going to the
towards the red flag and capture it and
they want to now bring it back to their
own base and the trick is that you
really need to have your flag at your
base to score and that's that's why you
need coordination for example now their
flag has been stolen by the red agent
and so they need to tag that red agent
and get their flag back before they can
score score a flag of their own now the
types of environments that you see here
we have - we have an outdoor version you
know one that's placed in some kind of
desert setting and here we have an
indoor version we wanted to show that
the system can handle these two types of
very different terrains and specifically
what's interesting here is we use
procedural generation whereas you and I
we would probably play this game on the
same map every time or maybe it just
changed maps a few times what we require
the agents to do here is to play on a
different map every single time and here
you see a sample of these maps they all
look different and what that does is
when the agents learn to play on these
varied maps they learn to generalize
they learn robust strategies that work
in all kinds of maps rather than just
rote learning a particular map and so
the trick is also to train a population
of agents and you see here our training
setup there's a population of agents
down here and they connect to what we
call arenas each one of these is a
little game simulation and some sample
of these this population connects to the
games for agents to on blue side to on
red side they play they learn they get
feedback they win or they lose and then
that stream of experience is routed back
to those agents and that's where the
neural networks are updated and they
learn and they are trained pretty much
independently other than through their
interaction in the arena
Kirsten you're a network architecture
that we use it's a two level hierarchy
of recurrent neural networks a fast one
and a slow one so we can cover different
timescales and it also learns about the
reward signal because this problem is
very difficult if you only ever get a
reward signal at the end you know you
imagine you play a five-minute game of
capture the flag and in the end someone
tells you oh you just won or you just
lost and you now need to figure out
going back in the game what was it that
made me win or what was it that made me
lose wouldn't it be much better if you
had some intermediate rewards like oh I
just take the opponent that must have
been a good thing or I just got the flag
of the opponent and so that's what
happens at this top level when we learn
those rewards we also use a population
of agents because that allows us to get
some robustness towards different
playing styles different agents learn to
play the game in different ways and so
when agents train against these
different agents they again need to
develop robust strategies in order to
succeed in this game so here you see the
results and again we measure agent skill
in ello so the higher it is the better
and this is how they develop over time
you see here this is the baseline a
random atrum that doesn't do much it's
just chittering about you know randomly
naive self play doesn't quite work as
you can see here it's almost as bad as
the random here is the baseline of an
average human and here's the baseline of
a strong human and you see that the
agent the deep learning aid redeveloped
in this work learns and learns and
learns surpasses the average
surpasses the strong human and ends up
with a much higher skill than all of
them now one thing that we found
particularly nice is when we test it
with humans we also let them fill in
some questionnaires and we asked them so
which ones of your teammates was most
collaborative you know with whom could
you work the best and it turns out that
the human players indicated that they
liked it best to play with the AI big
you know they found it reliable and
strong and you know they wanted to play
with the AI so a nice finding now I'd
also like to use this example to show
you something that is maybe a little
underappreciated and it's the idea of
understanding how these trained agents
that behave in these arguably quite
clever ways in these environments
represent the world and in order to do
that we've here done a tease me
embedding like a two-dimensional
embedding of the internal states of the
agents as they play this game and we can
color the points by our knowledge of the
game situation for example here we know
that this these points represent
situations in which the agent flag is at
the base the opponent flag is at their
base and the agent is in their home base
you know we know that because we can
look at the game but the agents also
know that you know they know that this
is a particular type of situation and
they represented by internal activations
that are all similar to one another and
that are different from a different
situation like here where the agent flag
is taken the opponent flag is held by
the teammate and so somehow in their
internal representations they've learned
what a given situation is like and as a
consequence they can use that to make
the make good decisions about how to
play in those situations and good
decisions they make here are some
patterns of behavior that we've observed
and here for example home base defense
they try to defend their own home base
they sometimes camp in the opponent home
base you know they just
wait there until the flag responds and
they can they can steal it or they can
follow the teammate and really just work
together in in the same area and it
turns out that this most advanced agent
is actually most similar in playing
style to to the humans that we observed
playing and I just want to emphasize
there's a whole dimension of research
out there where we not only train these
systems but we look at their internal
representation how do they represent the
world and we look at their behavior and
really understand how they solve the
problem so that we can learn from that
but also ensure that they behave in safe
ways for example if it's a safety
critical problem good now we've seen
that in the in this more complex
multiplayer game the agents can clearly
reach human level it takes a lot of
compute to achieve that no doubt
training populations is important
because you want a diverse training
signal and the self play that still
worked for alphago for alpha zero didn't
actually work here because they just
learned one strategy and there wasn't
enough diversity and robustness in there
a second thing of course that makes
things robust is that we have diversity
of environments because they we
procedurally generate them and we can
begin to understand how these agents
behave and write this papers and blog
posts on this that you can read to pick
up more detail now as the third case
study I would like to go beyond games
and talk about how we can use deep
learning to learn to fold proteins and
the particular project I'll talk about
is called alpha fold and the paper is
called improved protein structure
prediction using potentials from deep
learning and is worked by my colleagues
Andres senior Richard Evans John jumper
and James Kirkpatrick and many others so
what is this about what is this protein
forwarding
first let's understand what proteins are
some of you may know more about this
than I do and but here's the gist there
are the fundamental building blocks of
life they carry out all kinds of
functions in our bodies they catalyze
reactions they transduce signals across
the cell membrane they regulate genes
they do cellular transport they they
provide antibodies and they're very
important for clinical drugs often they
are the target of particular drugs but
also many drugs are proteins and the key
thing we need to know to understand the
protein is its shape what the shape of a
given protein on the right here you see
this amazing animation of proteins in
action and you can see they really act
as molecular machines you know then they
can fulfill an amazing diversity of
functions in the body depending on their
shape now the interesting thing is that
in some sense the specification of a
protein is just a chain of amino acids
it's it's a sequence of amino acids from
an alphabet of 20 different amino acids
and what happens is that these amino
acids they interact locally to form
these shapes for example HeLa C's or
sheets and then these HeLa season sheets
they interact more globally to form the
3d shape of the overall protein and then
proteins can interact to do all of these
amazing things now the the problem that
we want to solve is that of protein
structure prediction and you have to
imagine that these proteins they have a
backbone it's basically the kind of the
main chain that determines their shape
and they have these little side chains
that that influence how these how this
backbone interacts with itself as it
folds back on itself and if we can
figure out from the sequence you know
this is the sequence of amino acids what
the 3d shape of the protein is then we
can understand what this protein does
because it acts when it's in this 3d
shape you can also imagine that if we
have a shape in mind that we want to
create it would be really good to have
this kind of mapping available because
then we could invert it and from the
desired shape device the sequence of
amino acids that we would need to create
in order to build the thing that falls
into that particular shape it's known as
the inverse problem now how can we think
about the shape of these proteins the
goal really is to predict for every atom
in this protein exactly where it ends up
when it folds but one way of
parameterizing this is through the
torsion angles and once we have all
these 2n torsion angles which are the
angles how these different bonds connect
to one another then we know the 3d shape
just imagine if you wanted to determine
the shape of these things someone told
you which way they rotate at each point
and you would be able to figure out
where they are so those are the
parameters that we're looking for once
we have these angles then we should be
done but there's a paradox and that is
called Leventhal paradox and it's
basically the following many naturally
occurring proteins fold reliably and
quickly to their native state despite
the astronomical number of possible
configurations so how if there are so
many ways in which these things can fold
how do they find the right way so that
they end up in exactly the shape that's
necessary in their living organism and
I've done a little example here so
suppose we have a chain length of 361
amino acids
and just at any point there are three
different ways in which they could fold
then we would have three ^ 361 is
roughly ten to the 172 configurations in
which they could fold now imagine these
proteins can wiggle really quickly and
they can explore ten to the thirteen
different configurations per second or
ten to the twenty per year that seems
like really quick search through that
space right but it would still take 10
to the 152 years to sample all the
possible configurations it's a huge
space and for those of you who know the
game of Go I have chosen 361 is the
example on purpose here because that's
the number of vertices and a go board
and three ^ 361 is an upper bound on the
number of legal go positions of all the
kind of ways in which you can have a go
position and John trump actually
calculated how many legal positions
there actually are in go and you see I
tend to get sidetracked to go because I
just love the game and he represents
that number as a ternary number and a
ternary number because any of these
points can have three states empty black
or white can be represented as a go
position and so this is the go position
that as rare if you read it as a ternary
number represents the number of legal
positions in the game of goal now you
might be wondering is it a legal
position it is an illegal position you
know there's a black stone here where it
shouldn't be and another one here and
that's actually accurate because the
majority of these configurations of a go
board are in fact not legal positions
but back to $11 per adducts there's a
huge search space but we know that deep
learning can do something about deep
search spaces so let's do that so why do
we want to use deep learning for protein
folding there are experimental methods
of course to determine the structure of
of proteins
but it's a very difficult modeling
problem we have data available 150,000
proteins in the protein data bank which
was founded in 1971 so this is a long
ongoing process but we have much less
data than for some of the other tasks
like speech recognition or image
recognition so it's a little harder
there's another advantage there is CASP
which is an assessment some kind of
competition that provides a benchmark
for protein folding so there's a way of
testing how well a system does so what
should we predict it turns out that the
3d structure of such a protein is fully
described by a dispair wise distance
matrix so if you have all of these
points in space if you know all the
pairwise distances between them then you
know what that configuration in space
looks like and so the main thing that's
being predicted in this system is this
distance matrix conveniently it looks a
bit like an image and you know images
we're good at at addressing with deep
learning here's how the Alpha fold
system works the sequence comes in here
and we generate certain features from
databases so it's not quite just using
the raw data but it's pulling in
features about these sequences from
databases and then it does its distance
predictions also some angle predictions
and it produces a score function and
this score function is a number that
measures for a given forwarding
configuration for that sequence how good
that foldings configuration is and it's
differentiable and if it's
differentiable we can do gradient
descent and we can optimize it and
that's really the key idea behind this
work I will not go into the details of
this deep dilated convolution
convolutional residual network but my
colleagues in the future lectures will
discuss
architectures in greater detail and you
will have no trouble understanding
what's going on here
once you've been through their lectures
that's just one thing be said it's a
very very deep neural network with 220
of these blocks one after the other
good how accurate are the predictions
the first thing we can compare is ground
truth of this distance matrix with the
estimates of the system and we find that
the system does a good job at capturing
not only short term interactions but
also long long-range interactions and
then we can compare the foldings
themselves and these are good examples
where the folding worked well but you
can see here that blue which are Alpha
false predictions and green are
reasonably well aligned so it the system
understands the gist of these proteins
and and how they forward the second step
is this gradient descent that we can do
now that we have a potential and energy
function if you like that we want to
optimize we can use gradient descent on
these angles and and just wiggle down in
these in this configuration space and
there you see that here in action it's
literally optimizing the coordinates of
all the different bits and folding in
the process trying to optimize the score
that has opted that it has estimated to
be a good potential for this problem
you started multiple times to discover
local optima but overall it's a gradient
descent operation now I said earlier
that one reason this was such a nice set
up for deep learning is that there's a
good assessment exercise and this is
cusp in this case calves 13 and it is a
it is a competition in which there are
82 chains that fold into some 3d
structures but they are not known to the
community yet they're kept secret and so
these chains are released one chain per
day for a period of time and then the
participating teams have three weeks to
return five guesses or predictions of
what they think that particular chain
will
forward into and it's a very popular
competition over 90 groups from
different labs across the world
participate and then they have a
particular scoring mechanism which boils
down to measuring how close the
predictions are to the to the ground
truth that has been determined by those
experimental techniques and this is a
fantastic piece of work designing this
competition and were indepted two
decades of work here of those people who
run the competition or the participants
but of course also those people who do
with the experimental work of producing
this data because that's hard work some
people estimate that for some proteins
it takes an entire PhD thesis to get the
3d structure and entire PhD thesis
that's a lot of work ok so here are the
results these are the different teams
that participated and in fact the deep
learning system comes out as the best
performing system in this in this
exercise so this deep learning based
distance prediction clearly works it
gives more accurate predictions of
contact between residues although it
estimates distance previously a lot of
systems used contact when they're close
enough to go to one another
closer than a test rooms but it also
delivers richer information because you
can imagine this is there's more
information in a distance than in the
binary signal or if something is
together or further apart right we have
more information and finally because
it's a smooth prediction and we get
these distances it's real numbers it's
also a smoother potential that is easier
to optimize and we see that's why the
gradient descent for finding the right
car configurations works there are many
limitations still of course the a
curious accuracy of the system is still
limited it doesn't work so well on some
some proteins or protein templates the
method depends on what we pull out of
that database so only because there's a
database of
structures can we get the features that
allow us to make those predictions and
also it only predicts the backbone and
we then use a tool called Rosetta to
fill in the side chains so it's it's one
small step in in a problem that has been
thought about and worked on for many
decades but it shows that deep learning
has something to contribute to these
problems in science and specifically in
biology good so that was the three case
studies that I wanted to present alphago
the classic if you like with its
extension into alpha zero a board game a
video game the game of capture the flag
with more players more richer
interactions harder to process visuals
and so on and finally an example from
the world of science where deep learning
can really make a contribution to
scientific progress in a field where
that matters because it might help
develop new new cures now I'd like to
use the rest of the time to give you an
overview of the field of deep learning
by going through the different lecture
topics that my colleagues are going to
talk about and here they are and we
start with number two because we just in
the process of doing number one the
first lecture away after this one is on
the foundations of neural networks and
will be developed at the delivered by
Wojtek Ronettes key and it will really
answer the questions what our neural
networks what kinds of functions can
they represent how are they trained you
know back propagation some review of
those ideas many of you will be familiar
with them but I can tell you when Roy
Tech explains these things then they
become clearer than they have ever been
and of course also what are the
limitations of neural networks
limitations of neural networks have led
to the first neural network winter men
decades ago when neural networks with
only a single layer were not able to
solve the simple XOR problem and when
only only adding a second layer to the
neural network then enables the system
to solve this kind of problem so that's
these things are important to know the
second lecture after that or a number
lecture number three will be on
convolutional neural networks for image
recognition given by sundar dilemma and
the idea here is really to pick up on
the on the thought that we want to imbue
the neural network with a form of prior
knowledge because that will make
learning more efficient than more data
efficient and introducing convolutional
neural networks is one way of doing that
convolutions encode a particular week
prior about how images behave for
example they can encode translation
invariant you know no matter where an
object is in the in the image it will
still be the same thing and we'd like to
encode these things in our neural
networks and convolutional neural
networks brainchild of Jung Lacan in his
little net five work they really
revolutionized image recognition because
they made these neural networks
competitive for these tasks and nowadays
every neural network application in the
area of vision makes use of
convolutional neural networks now in the
next lecture Viorica Petrossian will
talk about vision beyond image net and
object recognition and talk about more
advanced models and this might involve
object detection semantic segmentation
you know what is what in a given scene
estimation of optical flow she will also
talk about analysis of videos videos can
be viewed just as stacked images in time
and there are interesting tasks there
for example action recognition from a
single frame you might not know what
someone is doing but if you see a video
of it then there's an action going on
you might want to recognize
what that is you know for example
someone smashing in the window or doing
a sports exercise the next thing is self
supervised learning one problem that
deep learning is plagued with is that it
are it's supervised variant depends on
labels you know when we learn object
recognition we need a photo and a label
what's in it so to speak but in self
supervised learning we can learn a lot
about the world without labels and this
is particularly interesting if you have
multiple modalities think of a video on
YouTube there's a video stream but
there's also an audio stream and the
audio can tell us something about the
video and the video can tell us
something about the audio and so we can
learn representations from that the next
lecture is on optimization for machine
learning given by James Martin's so you
can think of optimization as the engine
that drives the learning process and of
course it's a very old field how to how
to optimize functions and he will focus
in particular on gradient based
optimization methods and their
application to training neural networks
he'll cover gradient descent momentum
methods second-order methods and
stochastic methods and just to give you
an example this is a visualization of
the error surface of the lost surface of
a neural network you see it's a complex
beast it has this fine substructure
everywhere with local optima there's a
super interesting result in particular
in this paper here mode connectivity
that there are all of these little
Optima this local Optima but there's a
path between them where when you walk
along purl in the parameter space along
this path all the solutions along that
path are relatively good solutions that
generalize well and those connect those
modes and you know there's a lot of
complexity here in those lust surfaces
and we need to understand optimization
to to become good at training these
neural networks
I will then move on to sequences and
recurrent networks delivered by Marta
gar nello
and this is again the idea that we want
to imbue the neural network with prior
knowledge but this time its knowledge
about time its knowledge about sequences
maybe the idea that in a sequence for
what happens now more recent stuff have
matters more than stuff that happened
longer time ago and why is this
important well if you think about it a
lot of data comes in the form of
sequences speech text DNA sequences
video audio they're all sequences we
might think of vectors that's like the
first thing that we learned in machine
learning but almost all the interesting
stuff comes in sequences and so she will
discuss recurrent neural networks and
also the famous LST M's long short-term
memory which is a way of dealing with
the problem of vanishing gradients in
training recurrent neural networks
another interesting task here is
sequence to sequence learning suppose
you want to translate one language to
another
that's one sequence to another and so
there's there's ways of training neural
networks to do that as well we'll then
move on to deep learning for natural
language processing in some sense a
special case of the previous work and
Felix will discuss why deep learning is
a good technique for language and he'll
discuss simple recurrent your networks
apply to language but also more complex
models up to transformers which is one
of the most successful models he'll also
talk about unsupervised learning because
not every piece of text is labeled so
what can we learn if we just have a dump
of Wikipedia or reddit you know a vast
amount of text can we learn something
about language from that without having
labels and finally he'll also talk about
subtle things like situated language
understanding you know what does the
situation of a particular agent tell us
the grounding the interaction of
language in the world here's just a tiny
example of some recent very exciting
work in language modeling you know where
they train this huge model I think on
the reddit corpus of a lot of data and
it's a system that you can prompt with
some input text and it will then produce
a continuation of that text and it
produces very fluent text I'll just read
the completion but you know it's about
the prompt is about scientists
discovering unicorns you know pretty
absurd but the model just keeps going
the scientists named the population
after the distinctive horn of its unique
urn these four horned silver white
unicorns were previously unknown to
science you know it's kind of
superficially makes sense you listen to
it and it sounds like English right
what's going on so then Alex graves will
talk it will turn your and his attention
to attention and memory in deep learning
which are emergent topics that are very
important we know of course that for
human cognition attention and memory are
very important but can you renege works
and body these ideas it turns out that
they can and you can even foreign normal
in your network see that it will pay
particular attention if you like to some
parts of the input rather than others to
solve particular tasks we call that
implicit attention but we can also make
that explicit we can build mechanisms
that allow the neural network to zoom in
on particular parts of the input to put
its attention there if you like
and the highlight of that lecture might
well be the idea of the neural Turing
machine or differentiable neural
computer where there's a neural network
controller that has access to an
external memory that can write to it and
read from it and it can solve problems
in this way for example it can write the
graph of the of the London Underground
system into this memory and then answer
questions about it about the
connectivity of that graph so that
should be an interesting one
now then move to unsupervised learning
in particular generative latent variable
models and variational inference
by Andreini and I already mentioned
unsupervised learning is very important
because we don't have labels for a lot
of tasks and in particular and
interesting model that he will consider
is the auto encoder model at the
variational auto encoder model and the
idea here is that from data you might
want to infer some latent variable
responsible for generating that data for
example there's the image of a digit and
you might want to determine what the
label of that digit is but then given
the label of that digit you might want
to generate images of those digits and
training these jointly is the model of
the variational auto encoder and it's a
very powerful model for unsupervised
learning when you don't have labels but
when you need your system to learn the
underlying representation then in
lecture 10 will continue with work on
unsupervised learning with the focus on
representations and this will be
delivered by me al or Oscar and Irina
Higgins
and they'll ask the question what is a
good representation which of course is
task dependent but can we characterized
how we would like to represent the world
and they'll argue that unsupervised
learning has the potential to address a
lot of the open problems that deep
learning is struggling with for example
the large amount of data of labelled
data that is needed and they will
discuss different approaches to this
here's a little example there's a data
set of 3d or of 2d projections of 3d
chairs and you know they just come in
the the system is just confronted with
those how would it structure its
perception of those it turns out that
this bethe variational auto encoder is
able to find different angle dimensions
in this chaos where for example here's a
dimension along which the rotation of
the of the chair is discovered as one
independent dimension the width of the
chair is discovered as another
independent dimension and the leg style
is discovered as yet another independent
dimension so this algorithm is thrown at
this collection of data and it discovers
what we would call natural factors in
this data and that of course can be very
useful for downstream tasks in lecture
11 we'll talk about generative
adversarial networks
this is delivered by Mahalo rasca and
Jeff Donohue and this is a particularly
fascinating recent development namely a
model a generative model for data that
is based on a little game that is being
played it's really multi agency to
agency there are two planners the
generator that generates data and it
discriminate that tries to discriminate
if I want to generate a generated if
that's the genuine image for the data or
if it's just something that there was
Maori generate and by thing is name in
gradient space if you like this is gonna
make it becomes better measuring what
the generals from real data but the
generator becomes better and better at
fooling the discriminator to generate
data that really looks like real data
and there are now many variations of
this it's in Goodfellow started this
work in 2014 and it's it's one of the
very interesting and hot topics in deep
learning now finally and I'm very happy
that we have this in the program the
last lecture will be on the topic of
responsible innovation and will be given
by our son Gabriel and Charlie chin and
the thought here is that AI provides
powerful tools that are shaping our
lives and our society but that of course
with the great power that we can wield
here also comes great responsibility and
we would like to address that in this
final lecture in two ways the first one
is about building safe robust and
verified AI systems that do what we
like them to do for example you hear you
see an example of an adversarial example
where a classifier classifies this image
correctly as a deer but if you add just
a tiny bit of noise to it the right kind
of noise adversarial noise it will then
miss classify almost the same image as a
bird so these systems are not robust and
we need to understand the boundaries of
what these systems can do and there's a
whole field developing around this idea
that we need our AI systems to be a lot
like normal engineering reliable and
robust and so on and we're beginning to
understand how to do this better and
better and the second aspect of this
lecture is how to think about the ethics
ethical consequences of building AI
systems and more as a joke and the
starting point I've put here the Three
Laws of Robotics by Asimov the science
fiction writer because you know already
80 years ago he was thinking about the
consequences of deploying AI systems in
the world and had some idea of how they
would need to be thought about the
ethics of this and what kinds of laws
they should be following and of course
now we are confronted with systems that
actually do influence the world you know
you have questions of employment where
where there's automation and AI systems
can now do a lot of the jobs that that
humans can do more and more in the
future probably you have the questions
of of bias and fairness that these
systems inherit certain properties from
the datasets that they learned from that
we might not agree with and that we
might want to change maybe an
opportunity to change some things here
and so yes and we'll we'll talk about
these aspects of our work in AI close
the series of lectures okay that's all I
had to say thank you very much now we
have some time for questions do you have
any yes please yes so the question is
what are the most important limitations
of deep learning and if there are any
there are plenty I would say it's an
emergent technology if I had to name my
number one it would be the lack of data
efficiency so with all of these examples
I've shown we had a lot of data
available in these reinforcement
learning scenarios we generated a lot of
that data ourselves but in other
settings we might need to draw on
existing data sets and they might just
be limited in size for example in the
protein folding situation we have these
150,000 folded proteins with a lot of
duplicates but that's not actually that
much data for what deep learning
requires and my colleagues used a lot of
data augmentation techniques to squeeze
out the maximum of information out of
this so that would be my number one data
efficiency because as humans we are also
we're very data efficient in our
learning and if we could approach that
with deep learning I think that would be
great another one of my concerns that is
a little related to it is energy
consumption because these computational
systems also consume a lot of energy and
we know that our brain works on roughly
20 watts like that's a dim light bulb so
how how can we bridge that gap that's
another one of those and then on the
side of a I I think there's way to go in
questions like flexibility and common
sense you know what we might
characterize as fluid intelligence our
it
to quickly adapt to a new question to a
new situation to understand to act
appropriately those are the big areas to
work on plenty of key ftcc's out there
yeah so I think they go in the right
directions but they're really only the
the beginning of the path the goal your
you asked you correctly characterizes
that we want this generality these many
different things and how do how do these
settings help us in the entire games
there clearly is a set of very different
games that characterize you know that
that require a very different behavior
so there is some diversity there is it
enough diversity you know ideally we
would have a less constrained setting
more real-world noisier with more
different challenges that's true but I
think you have to see the trend you know
for example in alphago we started with a
single game and a lot of human knowledge
that came into it and then we
generalized it to three different games
that the system can now play and of
course it could be trained on other
games as well so we expanded the class
of things and I think the game we're
playing here is we want to always expand
the class of things that we can do with
our available methods and and eventually
have a very large pool of things that
can be done
yes that's a good question so does this
autonomous driving take us somewhere
near our real intelligence because it
requires the right reaction in so many
different scenarios another way that we
think about this is is autonomous
driving AI complete is it true that if
you can flawlessly drive and have a
self-driving car does that mean that you
have a full intelligence and I think
it's it's kind of in between but because
there still comes some constraints there
but it is it's almost like that because
there is such a wide variety of
different scenarios as you're describing
and currently systems don't have the
flexibility to react to these so I don't
think the the right approach here is to
to just add data and try to sample that
space of situations we need to come up
with new ideas how the system can reason
about about the world you know maybe
with physical models maybe with multi
agent models because a lot of the
predictions we do in in traffic are
based on our understanding of what the
other agents want you know does this
agent want to dis car want to overtake
me what does that bicycle ride I want to
do do they want to turn so all of these
things so I think as we improve our
understanding of how to model physical
systems how to model multi-agent systems
and how to acquire common sense then
we'll be approaching autonomous driving
it's a beautiful example because it's
kind of it's so clear what we want to do
here in autonomous driving yet it is so
hard other questions yes please
that's a good question are we entering
into the new caste competition I don't
know
but my colleagues are certainly very
passionate about the problem and and
work has continued on protein folding
for us this protein folding this this
was one step in that work and but we're
in that for the long term so they are
certainly interested yes please right
yeah so the question is if we do
reinforcement learning with say two
agents that train against one another
will they explore the whole space of
possibilities or could they be get stuck
in some particular part of strategy
space so that's that's a very real
concern even in a single agent
reinforcement learning setting the
problem of exploration versus
exploitation is a huge problem so in
order to reach long-term reward maximize
long-term reward the agent needs to
explore the system and figure out what
works and what doesn't but at the same
time it can then not exploit what it
already knows about the system because
if it only exploits it will not find out
about other parts of that space so even
in single agent RL exploration is a huge
problem in a 2-player self play kind of
scenario it can be a problem but we were
able to overcome it with a bit of
randomization in in alpha zero that has
somehow led led it to explore a lot of
other options but in the
capture-the-flag work we went one step
further and we created a pool of diverse
players that play differently and and
that was in an attempt to address
exactly the problem we're pointing out
because that
a single player then to have a strategy
that can deal with a number of other
opponent strategies and even teammate
strategies and they that's the same type
of robustness that that we're looking
for in other intelligent systems you
know be able to deal with a large
variety of situations p-nut environments
or opponents or teammates that's exactly
the question yeah again that's a very
good question how do we measure that one
way of measuring it is by doing
experiments with humans because humans
are incredibly good at figuring out the
patterns and finding counter strategies
and that's why we did both in alpha go
and alpha zero but also in the capture
the flag work we benchmarked with humans
and they did find some interesting
strategies an alternative is to Train
yet another agent that is just designed
to exploit the given agent that that
we're trying to test it's just designed
to find the weaknesses in it and if
reinforcement learning works then that
agent will find weaknesses in it and in
the alpha star work where my colleagues
applied deep learning and RL to the game
of StarCraft they had explicit exploiter
agents in the pool they were training
against whose sole role was to exploit
the given agents as being trained to
avoid it from developing degenerate
strategies any other questions yes
you immediately works for such as in
makeup to the black case where you never
work for tagging the therapist if you
capture many points for that
your agent might decide to ignore the
game and just go around attacking
enemies yeah a nice place and if that's
true yes that's that's a good question
so it is a big problem how do we specify
a reward function such that the
resulting system that optimizes them
actually solves the problem that were
interested in and the the answer is
sometimes simple in the game of go that
last you know you want a win rather than
lose so there is clear in the game of
capture the flag it's also clear you
also want to win that game but it's such
a spaz reward signal that you want
intermediate rewards and the way we did
it in that work I didn't dwell on that
is we actually learned a wait for the
different game events that we can
observe you know capture a flag tag an
opponent be tagged your flag being stole
and so on there's a whole list of game
events those are the events that real
players of this game gets points for in
the game and we learned a waiting
function for these and the weighting
function was learned to optimize for the
final outcome go up and so there is a
way of bootstrapping the learning
process from the final outcome to denser
more informative reward signals that the
RL agents can then pick up on it's one
way of solving it I think okay I'm
afraid you need to wrap up our terms up
I hope we can welcome you to the next
lecture on the basics of neural networks
by a Vortech have a great evening
Thanks
[Applause]
you